hello in this video we'll be talking
about blue white screening as the name
suggests it's a screening process after
after cloning the bacteria after cloning
the gene of interest into certain
bacteria we use this particular blue
white screening strategy to select our
recombinant colonies so if we walk
through the workflow of cloning we will
understand the necessity of doing our
screening so first in order to do the
cloning you need to restriction digest
your vectors with restriction enzymes
then you have to also restriction digest
your gene of interest with the same
restriction enzyme the next step would
be the ligation of these two think to in
order to get the recombinant plasmid
once we get the recombinant plasmid then
we can transfix'd
I mean we can transform that into a
complete in bacteria so actually I would
eat up the plasmid and as we grow the
bacteria bacteria would grow in number
and so as our gene of interest would
grow in number as well but there is a
problem if we think about the culture
system there could be one possibility
that the transcription efficiencies
the transformation efficiency is low and
that is why some of them actually has
not taken out the plasmid but this
problem could be solved easy
so some of the bacteria have the plasmid
some of the bacteria might not have the
plasmid but the bacteria which has the
plasmid has the antibiotic resistance
gene as well right now when you are
preparing the media you're putting
antibiotic into the media so if the
bacteria don't have a antibiotic
resistance gene it would die it would
simply die it cannot survive in that
environment only if the vector E has
antibiotic resistance gene it can
survive without the antibiotic
resistance genes it cannot survive so
this problem is solved but there is
another problem the second problem is
now in in the solution there could be
two type of plasmids like one is just
self like it it plasmon on recombinant
and something there could be like
recombinant plasmid now how to
understand that the bacteria : that is
formed have the recombinant one not the
self ligated one so in order to do this
you need some screen herbal markers and
very often the screen oval marker is
present in the form of a particular
reporter gene in this case the reporter
gene is Lexie Lexie is present in the
multiple cloning site now if we clone
our gene of interest in the multiple
cloning site the lac reporter gene would
be kind of perturbed because we are
inserting into the locus of legs we gene
so its product won't be formed so Lexie
normally give rise to beta galactosidase
now beta galactosidase would convert
x-gal into a colored product so that
would make the bacterial colony looking
blue now if you insert the gene of
interest into that particular Lac C
containing multiple cloning site then
what would happen with AG electricity's
won't be produced because leg switching
is already disrupted so this is called
insertional inactivation gives you the
insertion of your gene of interest the
legs the gene is inactivated and as a
result beta galactosidase is not
produced so the X scale can not be
cleaved and it cannot produce any color
as a result the bacterial colonies which
have this kind of recombinant plasmid it
would have white but at the end of the
day there could be two different type of
plasmid so in a plate you would have
some colonies which are blue and some
colonies which are white so remember the
white colonies are those colonies which
are recombinant because in these
colonies the back the bacteria has the
recombinant gene and due to the
insertion of the gene there is an
inactivation of the legs that is why
these colonies are white and that
explains why do you need a screen able
system and why it is useful
and once you can see and understand that
okay the white colonies are recombinant
you would pick up those colonies and
cultured them in buck once you cultured
them you can isolate the plasmid and
keep the plasmid in minus 20 or minus 80
degree centigrade for future use so this
was the overall of you why screw noble
marker is important or what is actually
blue-white screening so this is widely
used screening method in molecular
biology I hope you enjoyed this video if
you liked this video give a big thumbs
up don't forget to like and share and
subscribe